your official 2018 San Diego comic-con
preview everyone Jenny here is that time
of year again the biggest weekend in pop
culture comic-con and I'm talking to to
comic-con Queens Queen vets in their own
please welcome ash crossing and Leanne
Aguilera are you guys your vets I want
to know what we can expect from the con
let's start with film what I start with
film because I think a lot of people
think this is one of the more bleak
years in terms of film it has nothing to
do with like comic-con being over any of
those speculations yeah even dude it's
just a down cycle of a year and and we
and I'll speak to the TV about deficit
but you know Marvel's not going because
they can't really say anything because
we got to wait for to find out what
happens with infinity war and then
you've got Star Wars they're not really
attending more on that later but they're
they're just starting production of
episode knives that they've just got and
there's just nothing to it now yeah
they've got their years but I think if
some of these Studios play right it's
actually gonna be a really really big
year for Sony and DC slash Warner
Brothers the Warner Brothers panel is
always like the most lit you know and
they pull out all the stops
it's like surrounded with screens and
all this crazy stuff but I think that
Aquaman is the big DC film it's coming
out in December they're probably gonna
drop a trailer they just dropped that
really colorful beautiful poster sir
it's just like James Wan it's gonna be
like and they showed a little here a
little bit of oh he looks like JSON boy
I mean man I think they dropped a little
bit of a teaser of it last year so it's
kind of this full circle moment of
finally getting what the trailer even is
is another what's so crazy about
comic-con is like we hear about these
movies so long I mean there's people who
are doing a lap now you know they're
like Aquaman especially with the the DC
water oh my god no pun intended that was
good with the DC one because their slate
has just been that everything's kind of
come and gone and gotten canceled and
pulled off so a lot of things that we
are talking about like five years ago
we're finally coming out finally here
and then there was our of some photos of
Shazam that just
on entering weekly so I believe we're
probably gonna get a little more of that
and then Wonder Woman 1984 is obviously
they're filming but patty Jenkins has
been posting stills so I don't think
it's impossible that we could get a
little something there maybe some stills
we haven't seen maybe one of those like
hey couldn't make it from set video
messages that we frequently get
hopefully her in the costume right and
I'm also wondering if we're gonna get
some kind of surprised you know Ezra
Miller could possibly be there for
fantastic beasts so maybe they could
talk about that flash movie or also kind
of this is a little specific but the
writer of bumblebee is writing the
Batgirl movie right so maybe they can
have some kind of an out there like a
plot or something like that well and
then spoiler alert they just announced
that there is a Batgirl series in
development at the CW's need to know as
well so so much back row love there's so
much going but my spidey senses are
tingling feeling that you oh my gosh yes
because Sony is attending right and they
did spider-man homecoming and then just
to like sum up the complications of it
it's like kind of part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but not really it's
like a little bit of a Venn diagram
here's where the exist Marvel's over
here and Sony's over here right but they
have venom which is the r-rated
spider-man universe movie starring Tom
Hardy they're definitely gonna be
showcasing the trailer was a little
underwhelming okay there was a lot of
memes lots and lots of memes I'm ready
to be I don't know what the Sony Twitter
account is doing right now you gotta
check it out they're gone really
off-the-wall the commenters were a
little venomous about venom Wow the puns
are on points today
no but correct me if I'm wrong ash
comic-con is the place where you pull
out all the stops right yeah it's like
they could be cutting maybe something
special for the panel right or bright
carpet or for that yeah and it's really
you get you know how many people sixty
five hundred people in the hall that's
that many people in the room who know
nothing about the movie they line up
overnight it's where you really just
ramped up the excitement
so this is the place to do it and then
on in kind of a spider-man thing they
have into the spider verse which is this
like beautifully animated looking movie
and it's not it's not like a spider-man
movie in this same like timeline realm
thing but it's from Lord Millar who were
supposed to direct solo they're
deliberating that and it looks totally
amazing it's with them it's Miles
Morales it's not Peter Parker we got the
right people because also Peter Parker
is also a knight I don't know there's a
lot going on there but it looks
beautiful
I'm sure there's a video coming on that
just to break it up yeah yeah yeah it's
like I'm thinking like they'll probably
push a little something there I don't
know moving on right right paramount is
bringing bumblebee jolly begin abuzz you
guys that's the Transformers spin-off
yeah I never liked Anna yeah takes place
in the 80s oh it's like bumblebees
origin story I never leak like got super
into this franchise but it's like Hailee
Steinfeld I really like her the female
led eighties transformers movie like I
could take it and people loved bumblebee
like I did watch all the Transformers
films I don't know why but yeah but
bumblebees that character I think people
are most drawn to so it was inevitable
to get his own spin-off and the 80s like
we we're gonna get so many great jams
coming out of bumblebee oh yeah there
was already like a teaser where their
bumblebee gets rickrolled mm-hmm and
immediately spits out the cassette tape
absolutely not no be music can help you
say what you're feeling
try this
[Music]
and then we have 20th Century Fox of
course they're bringing the predator
which is cool like I'm down with that
movie but I'm really interested in their
other titles and they did this last year
with Kings main goal for the Golden
Circle they just did a Kingsman panel
and didn't talk about anything else and
I feel like this is really the place
where you like to mention all your x-men
movies and you talk about Dark Phoenix
and the New Mutants and I am like 99%
sure they're not even gonna bring them
so do you think it's just gonna be press
I think it's just gonna be the predator
Oh coach is kind of crazy because it's
you know this crazy put some star power
though Olivia much you know yeah like
it's gonna be really cool but I'm like
um but the really like craziest film
news out of all of this is who's taking
that coveted Hall H spot on Saturday
evening for movies and it is drumroll
please yeah movies Bell Bay now yeah um
I guess they're promoting the home
release I've stuff like kind of
unprecedented and crazy but they're also
gonna be screening this like long uncut
Director's Cut version yeah I mean I
think it's just gonna be like super
weird yeah I mean I guess this is a
great thing like from a TV fans point of
view you can actually discuss all the
spoilers and there were a lot of
spoilers from that movie so they like
especially like the mid-credits scene
and people want to know if that's canon
oh yeah oh yeah I want to talk all about
exactly so if you so the hardcore fans I
have something for them they're all eh
even though difficult is out
yeah it's interesting Romilly movies is
just teeing things up but this is
actually really cool like I like this
it's like as if it's the end of a season
that you can discuss all the spoilers
afterwards I agree and I'm here for I
really like doing you know those
interviews where we get to talk to
people like well after the movies out
cuz I'm like when you're doing those
like premiere interviews and those junk
and interviews you see with the poster
in the background I can't really talk
about spoilers like we're not gonna be
the one for to spoil the movie for
everybody so I like it kind of later
where we're just like all right yeah
let's talk about ABS it brings it back
to the roots of comic-con like this is a
place and a an experience with fans yeah
like people who are hardcore but it
really isn't about us as much as we'd
like to think of it oh but it's kind of
about you it is oh I'm going to okay so
there's no Star Wars movies at comic-con
but there
doing a special panel for the 10th
anniversary of the Clone Wars which I
will be attending that's the animated
show that was a 2008 but my shameless
plug is that if you want to come see me
and say hi to me and talk about servers
I'll be on a panel like being the one
talking oh I'm gonna be talking about
star wars tourism I'm what it's like to
visit some of the locations because I
visited Ireland I'm gonna talk about
octo and skellig michael up orgs of
course hahaha
video as you guys can tell yeah so if
you do see me come love sweets should we
move on to what we can expect in the TV
world I don't big screen to the small
screen like the TV stuff is like the
cream of the ground come on they TV
dominates comic-con and even though kind
of similar on the movies vein it's gonna
not have as much of the star power you
know Game of Thrones is it going this
year West world isn't going cuz they're
filming the next season stranger things
is in the middle of production so a lot
of these like heavy hitters won't be
there but that doesn't mean that other
big casts won't be there of course The
Walking Dead will be back for Season 9
epic which is insane and this could be
the very last year that Andrew Lincoln
is on the panel because he's said to be
leaving the show after season 9 so we
will be saying bye-bye to that zombie
killer end of an era end of an era end
of an era and then of course the Walking
Dead prequel series fear The Walking
Dead is now an after series there was a
massive time jump and they're also gonna
be there to kind of fill in some of our
biggest undead questions that are
lingering and then in other AMC news the
not-so-distant blip like blast from the
past
Breaking Bad is coming to comic-con it
is a reunion panel there's a lot of them
oh yeah because it's the 10th
anniversary anniversary I mean that's
gonna get a lot of family exactly
exactly science fish over in the world
of reboots the CW is bringing their
charmed series and of course so
basically three sister witches but this
is now from the creator of Jane the
Virgin who of course has gotten a lot of
whole claim you know Gina Rodriguez won
the Golden Globes so we will see how
well this show does I think that it's
going to be a pretty enchanting panel
and I'm not just saying that wow I'm on
fire yeah hold on let's back it up me a
little spellbinding anyways that's on
Thursday ballroom 20 at 11:15
moving on to some really cool really
cool groundbreaking news you know doctor
who is coming to comic-con this year and
for the first time in the series 55 year
history the doctor is a woman I am so
excited the thirteenth doctor will be
played by Jodie Whittaker
she is coming there will be some new
footage we really don't know much about
the way that she's gonna be playing the
doctor I've heard that it's gonna be
very similar to Matt Smith kind of like
eyes wide open very precocious very
excited and that feels like it's gonna
be a really great place for new fans to
come and join Doctor Who so I know that
your eyes are kind of glazing over John
now well that was it that was the thing
is last year that had just been
announced exactly exactly and now we
have her and now we get to me and now we
get to meet her um you know Netflix
slash Marvel they're not really bringing
last year they had defenders yeah and we
were also gearing up for Jessica Jones
season 2 this year they're bring
bringing Iron Fist who in my opinion
without sugar I'm really trying he is my
least favorite out of all of them so if
you're into arrow ripoffs you can check
that panel off to the actual arrow show
along with the rest of the CW super
lineup they will be bringing their mega
panel which they do every year it is a
four-part multi hour-long multiverse
situation with arrow the flash Supergirl
and DC's legends of tomorrow I mean is
that like the one is that like that is
like the panel it starts on Saturday in
ballroom 20 at 3:30 and then it goes
until 6:30 OMA oh yeah oh it's a lot
there's so much information we're gonna
get even
on the new CW series Batgirl or Batwoman
Oh whoever's coming out right now and
then if you stay until the very end for
the flash which in my opinion is the
best of the four shows I have the
pleasure of moderating that so that will
be super fun and I can tell you there's
going to be plenty of season five scoop
that I get to see those shows are going
strong to them like arrow alone what
season is it arrow is gonna be going
into season seven and saying the long
yes I love it but there's one little
show if you guys have heard about it
Riverdale are moving on up because last
year they were in ballroom 20 which
hosts about 4,800 people this year
they've got the coveted Hall H spot on
Sunday so you know I actually know that
their moderator is going to be someone
special I will let them reveal that but
so if you're a river Delphian you won't
want to oh and some of these people will
be in the eat cheese sweet you guys we
will be down there they will be doing
interviews all over comic-con I'll be
there of course hosting daily Danny but
also bringing you guys a little bit of
color
we know that world and the madness and I
experienced it firsthand myself last
year and I want to give you guys a
little case of what you can expect again
on the con floor take a look all right
you guys we get a flex flex the camera
these guys out wait
no okay if you blink you might miss them
it's the flat oh my god dammit there
goes my exclusive so how does it feel to
be Halle Berry's nephew um she never
comes to Christmas so there's that she
busy um you know I get it but it you
know a Christmas party help you know
something yeah some money do like a
grandma put fine I was in the car she
don't even do that
can we get a stocking stuffer
[Music]
what are you
maybe that poor lady Deadpool oh my god
lady Ryan Reynolds pleasure to meet you
are you excited for Deadpool - yeah so
excited to see my husband thank your
husband Oh Blake Lively I'm a huge fan
and how much work went into it I'm sorry
I'm trying to keep my eyes up here but
nothing a month just a minute left game
look at these party people coma cops fun
you guys don't be fooled by the rocks
and I got I carry our own equipment
I am hot can you just fan me real quick
I know it's comic-con but I'm still on
camera I already failed I'm not wearing
a costume so you got to start waiting in
line for Hall H come on you're like way
behind people started waiting yes gotta
go girl tell them a fish out of water
and but excited to be there again I'm
excited you guys will be there thank you
so much for all that amazing
Jenni scoop Oh guys you're headed to San
Diego right after this so thanks for
watching and like I mention you guys
daily Denny's gonna be on the road
coming to you live from comic-con maybe
these guys will make an appearance you
don't know who can come by or the et
sweet but thanks for watching make sure
you guys are subscribe to eat is YouTube
channel or following us here on Facebook
watch right we'll see you at the con
guys bye